uh he's not here yet so
hello
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast epigenomics of common rare and
somatic variants underlying disease and
cancer i am bob woodard of labrutz and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event
you can submit questions by typing them
in the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem to the
green q a button lower left
now i would like to introduce today's
speaker manolis kellis
dr telus is a professor of computer
science at mit
where he directs the mit computational
bio biology group
please join me in welcoming dr kellis
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
so thank you all for coming
i hope you can hear me well
um what i'd like to tell you about
all right can you hear me now
uh could you hear anything that i said
until now
okay so maybe i'll start the talk again
i'm really sorry
um okay so just to summarize very
briefly my introduction i will talk
about how epigenomics can in fact allow
us to understand common rare and somatic
variants than underlying disease and
cancer the promise of g was is to reveal
new mechanisms target genes therapeutics
and to enable personalized medicine but
the challenge is that there's a large
number of variants in the same linkages
equilibrium block
making it impossible to discover which
of the many snips are in fact causal
moreover most of the variants are known
coding and the cell type of action is
not known and the mechanism is not known
so the remedy for this is to actually
provide a systematic annotation of the
non-coding genome that allows us to link
enhancers to their regulators and to
their target genes and to develop new
methods for utilizing them in order to
be able to predict disease-relevant cell
types target genes genetic variants
upstream regulators the relevant
pathways and the cellular phenotypes
so what i'll talk about in this
particular presentation is number one
how do we build a reference map of the
regulatory genome that allows us to
distinguish
near uh
regulatory elements that are near
the beginning of the gene known as
promoters that'll color in red digital
regulatory elements uh known as
enhancers that are followed in orange
and then transcribed regions repressed
regions throughout color in
green and gray in order to understand
systematically the regions of
associations the cell types in which
they're acting the genes that they
target the nucleotides that are
underlying disease and the regulators
and uh i'll focus on three different
applications in the second part of the
talk number one understanding top
scoring geos hits
number two understanding weakly
associated variants that do not mean
genomic significance and
catching some of the hidden heritability
of the
genetic association studies
and number three understanding cancer
mutations that
underlie somatic variants
that arise and can lead to cancer
so here's the three parts of the talk so
first i'm going to talk about
characterizing the physionomic landscape
and then these three
applications of g was weakly associated
variants and
somatic variants so what is this
epigenomic roadmap that i spoke about
earlier uh it's a map that allows us to
now capture systematically the
epigenomic landscape of a large number
of primary tissues and cells
from adult samples embryonic samples as
well as
immortalized cell lines and cell lines
that are differentiated from them as
well as primary cells in a large number
of tissues and in each of those we map a
diversity of epigenomic assays
that allow us to characterize the
different
types of regions that i mentioned
earlier so using the same color code
promoter regions have very specific
marks enhancer regions have a different
set of marks transcribed regions have a
different set of marks so what are these
marks these marks are chemical
modifications that happen on the
keystone proteins that dna is wrapped
around
but also the accessibility of dna and
modifications that happen directly
on on the cpg the nucleotides of the
genome known as methylation marks
so we have systematically mapped a large
number of these histone modifications
open chromatin as well as the enemy
oscillation and the output of all of
these processes based on gene expression
by rna-seq in more than 100 different
cell types so the resulting data matrix
looks something like this where there's
a 127 different epi genomes and for each
of those we have a large number of
chromatin marks you can see here that
those five marks that i described
earlier are mapped on every genome and
then a large number of additional marks
are mapped in a subset of epigenomes
what is that allowed to do that allows
us to now look at an individual cell
type and look at the large diversity of
histomodification marks as well as dna
methylation rna expression
that are
mapped in each of those
and this is a screenshot from the washi
browser
and we can summarize all of that
information in a single annotation for
each cell type that allows us to
distinguish enhancer regions repress
regions transcribe regions based on the
combinations of these histone
modification marks as i mentioned
earlier
so
how do we do that we basically learn
model for the specific combination of
marks
based on a hidden markov model that
allows us to go through the genome and
discover a set of chromatin states that
allows to summarize combinations of
these histomodification marks and these
chromatin states cover a very diverse
fraction of the genome there are some
states that cover about 70 of every cell
type and these are quiescent states
where you don't see any of these marks
and then there's regulatory states uh
that are associated with promoters
enhancers that cover a total of less
than five percent of each genome and yes
these are the regions of the most
strongly conserved across different
species enabling us to now start
predicting
uh important regions if you wish in each
of the cell types where the regulatory
activity primarily happens
so we can use this to define chromosomal
domains using the expression of these
chromatin states for example you can see
here that about half the genome is in
fact inactive in the vast majority of
cell types but in fact the other half is
very very strongly active and these
regions that were discovered
primarily based on these chromatin
states actually exclusively based on
this chromatid state are in fact showing
very different gene density
very different associations with this
nuclear envelope marked by lamina
regions and they're also associated with
different chromosomal bands suggesting
that in fact these are domains
of the chromosome that are in fact
distinct in their function
so i focused until now on characterizing
the genomic landscape and now i'm going
to switch to using the differences
between cell types in order to reveal
patterns of activity
modules of co-regulated elements and
networks that link genes together
to their enhancer regions and their
upstream regulators
so we can now take one of these marks
h3k4me1 which is associated with
enhancer regions and actually build a
phylogeny of all of the different cell
types and i've color-coded the cell
types according to their biology for
example you can see that immune cells
are in fact all clustering together and
you can distinguish t cells from b cells
you can also see that brain samples are
all clustering together you can see that
induced pluripotent cells are clustering
together as well as embryonic stem cells
and you can also see for example that
fetal brain here groups with embryonic
stem cells rather than with the adult
brain you can see uh that
this clustering in fact captures a lot
of the common biology of uh immune brain
muscle heart smooth muscle and fetal
tissues
we can also visualize the
most extreme
cell types and samples using
this multi-dimensional scaling approach
that allows us to basically show that
immune cells and embryonic stem cells
are in fact the most extreme
followed by brain versus skin or fat
followed by muscle
and some of the
chromatin state coverage of these cell
types in fact allows us to understand
why they're so extreme and what makes
them so different for example embryonic
stem cells show a large enrichment in
these bivalent chromatin states that are
poised for either activation or
repression and you can see here that t
cells and b cells are for example
depleted in promoter regions
you can now exploit that information to
start understanding how the epigenomic
landscape in fact varies across these
127fp genomes so in a previous slide i
showed you one of these annotations all
the way up here for imr90 but in fact
you can see
that by having these annotations across
all 127 different cell types that have
been
mapped by roadmap of genomics and encode
you can actually see the dynamics of
different genes in different regions you
can see that some genes are consistently
active across different regions you see
that other genes are coming on and off
across different regions and you can see
that other genes are primarily repressed
and only turn on in very specific cell
types
the other thing you can see is how
different promoter regions are from
enhancer regions in their activity
patterns across cell types so these red
marks that are associated with promoter
function are in fact very stable you can
see these red columns
uh you know whether the gene is
expressed or not the promoters remain on
but when you look at enhancer regions
these orange marks you can see that they
are in fact much more dynamic and
they're in fact enabling us to now
perhaps learn
modules of coordinated activity across
these enhancer regions so we're going to
take all these enhancer regions that are
in orange and cluster them together
across the entire genome and we get a
picture like this so we have now 223
million
enhancer elements that are associated
with dna's accessibility and we can
cluster them into a small number of
activity patterns in this particular
case we've chosen 226 activity patterns
and what you can see here are the
vertical bars that are separating the
different patterns from each other and
every single one of these 2.3 million
enhancers laid side by side and the
first thing you'll notice is that
there's a very small number of these
enhancer regions that are ubiquitously
active but the vast majority are in fact
showing tissue-specific
or
linear specific function
and if you look at the genes associated
with them you actually see that they're
enriched in
functions that make a lot of sense
according to the tissues in which those
enhancers are expressed for example if i
trace here the
t cell
activity
the enhancers that are active in t cells
what you can see is that they're very
strongly enriched in immune functions
and you can also see that
enhancers that are active in the brain
are in fact enriched in learning and
memory functions which makes a lot of
sense and also suggests that these
enhancer modules are in fact enriched
in co-regulated
genes
and in order to uncover that we
basically looked at a set of regulatory
motifs that are previously characterized
across the genome and we search for
where do they occur in each of these
modules so we basically took these
modules of activity across there's 127
cell types and for each one of these
modules we basically ask what are the
regulatory motifs that are enriched in
that module and if i look at the
expression patterns of the corresponding
regulator for example spi-1 is the
expression of that regulator
correlated or anti-correlated with the
activity of the corresponding enhancers
and for spi-1 we find a positive
correlation enabling us to predict that
it is an activator rather than a
repressor and for rest two for example
we find a negative correlation
suggesting in fact that it is a
repressor consistent with its known
function of repressing brain
enhancers in non-brain tissues so that
allows us to now predict the systematic
catalog of these regulators for each of
these modules which we can visualize in
a simple way as a network of
that that links together
each of these regulators to the
corresponding cell types that make up
the activity of these modules and you
can see here for example that spi-1 is
predicted to regulate a lot of these b
cells and indeed it is a known regulator
of immune cells you can see here that
gata is associated with erythropoiesis
and you can see that this muscle
factor is in fact associated with both
muscle and heart again according to the
known biology you can also see that rfx4
is in fact associated with several
regions of the brain
and in indeed it has been known to play
various brain functions although this is
less recognized than some of the other
regulators
so we can also start linking enhancers
not just to their upstream regulators
that control them but also to the
downstream genes that they control and
to do that we did a similar clustering
similar as we had done previously for
the enhancer regions that i showed in
the previous slide but we now clustered
the gene expression patterns of each of
the corresponding genes and we were able
to then link
modules of enhancers to modules of genes
and that allows us to now have a much
more robust linking between individual
enhancers and individual genes through
the modules that connect them both which
are
much more robust because there's a much
smaller number of modules that are
actually being linked
we
validated these links based on
physical
connections
from chromatin conformation capture
across the whole genome known as high c
as well as protein centered interactions
uh using chia pet
and also genetic links predicted from
expression quantitative trait loci and
in each case we found that the
activity-based links are very good
predictors of each of these physical
interactions
or genetic interactions giving credence
to our method even though they observe
very different types of evidence they
seem to actually predict the same set of
links
so we have used epigenomics to
characterize the regulatory elements
active in each of a large number of cell
types and to understand the genomic
differences between cell types to find
extreme cells for example that show very
different activity patterns but we've
also exploited these activity patterns
to recognize modules of co-regulated
genes and co-regulated enhancers to link
these modules into networks that
actually predict both the option
regulators of each of these enhancers as
well as their downstream target genes so
now let's see how we can use that to
identify
disease-relevant tissues and regulators
so we built a simple model that
basically says that
enhancers that are targeted by the same
regulators
are more likely to be associated with
the same genetic condition
as evidenced by the single nucleotide
polymorphisms that are associated with
that condition but there is ambiguity
because every snip is in fact associated
with a large number of partners some of
which might lie in the same enhancer
region but some of which are lying in
different enhancer regions and this
ambiguity here can be resolved using
this iterative learning approach that
allows us to both predict the relevant
regulators for each of the trades as
well as the most likely causal snips for
each of these trades by systematically
predicting one using the other and
iterating so the input to this model is
a set of genome-wide association
p-values the regulatory network that
links each of these regulators to the
corresponding enhancer regions and
these enhancer regions to the
corresponding genes
as well as the genetic network linking
each of the snips to all of the regions
that that sniff might disrupt either
directly or indirectly through its
linkages equilibrium
partners
so the output of that model is a set of
trade relevant transcription factors a
state of causal sniffs and a set of
target genes
so here's a very simple example of
multiple regulators targeting the same
enhancer but each of these regulators
targets a lot of other loci across the
genome enabling us to predict which of
these regulators is the most relevant
for the specific trade
each of these regulators is linked to
one or more snips and they are also
linked to one or more enhancers enabling
us to now run our injective procedure
and predict both the set of target genes
and the set of regulators associated
with each trait as well as the specific
sniffs that are more likely to be
causal so here's an overview of the cell
types that are in fact the most enriched
for each of these loci so this is
looking very directly at a set of
genome-wide association studies so there
are 53 different traits here including
height
allergy
platelet volume
of cardiac trace such as the pr
repolarization interval
or
blood pressure
as well as cholesterol traits and
inflammatory bowel disease as well as
alzheimer's and now we can ask for each
of those traits
which
enhancers are the most enriched we
basically take all of the snips all of
the single nucleotide polymorphisms
across the whole genome for each of
these trades and then we ask do these
genetic variants tend to preferentially
lie
in regions that are active in specific
cell types
and that allows us to now find almost a
diagonal basically telling us that
different
diseases
are in fact enriched in different cell
types
and you can see in fact a lot of
concordance between immune traits that i
mentioned earlier and immune enhancers
that are active in t cells or b cells
you can find that for example blood
pressure is only enriched in one cell
type namely the left ventricle and you
can see
some surprising findings for example
inflammatory bowel disease has both an
immune component
and
a digestive component suggesting that
this regulation of both types of tissues
in fact is associated with
inflammatory bowel disease and you can
see here that alzheimer's disease
is not associated with brain at all
it is in fact instead associated with
immune cells
and
monocytes
that are
marked by cd14
and this is in fact a very interesting
story because we have independent
validation of that very unusual
association
whereby mice that are undergoing
neurodegeneration based on
alzheimer's like symptoms induced by the
p50 p25
protein
in their brains are undergoing two types
of changes number one they're undergoing
immune changes and activation of immune
components and number two they're
undergoing neuronal changes and
deactivation of neuronal components and
you can see these changes at the
expression level at the promoter level
and at the enhancer level and when you
look at human you see that the same
categories of genes are in fact enriched
in human patients based on expression
profiling of brains of human
patients of ad
and human controls you can also see that
specific immune regulators and neuronal
regulators are enriched in the
corresponding activated and repressed
components associated with alzheimer's
disease progression
but what's really striking is that the
enrichment
in
disease-associated variants
for these studies is happening primarily
in immune cells and in fact you see a
depletion
in these fetal brain samples
what this is suggesting is that in fact
immune cell dysregulation
is a causal component of alzheimer's
disease and this might be due to the
microglial cells which are resident
immune cells of the adult brain or the
macrophages that infiltrate brain in
neurodegeneration
so we've all known that
inflammation is in fact associated with
alzheimer's disease but this study
suggests that information might actually
be a causal component that leads to a d
rather than
simply a consequence of the
neurodegeneration
so this story is in fact highly
highlighting this particular link
between alzheimer's disease and
monocytes and immune cells rather than
the brain as we would have expected
perhaps
based on prior knowledge and it also
highlights
this much more general association of
immune traits with either t cells or b
cells
with um you know the heart
repolarization interval and blood
pressure as i mentioned earlier
specifically with the heart
and um
cholesterol specifically with liver so
it allows us to now associate each of
these different diseases with uh very
different tissues that might underlie
them that allows us to now go and study
specifically these tissues when trying
to uncover the mechanistic basis of each
of these diseases so we've made all of
these data publicly available all of
these predictions can be found through
haploreg
this
tool for browsing the regulatory
landscape of haplotypes associated with
disease so you can enter any snip or
energy with study and it will basically
tell you what are all of the
promoter elements enhancer elements
you know
regulators and regulatory motifs that
are associated with each of these
regions and you can try it out here
so let's now dive into
mechanistically dissecting these
disease-associated loci
and
using this new characterization of the
epigenomic landscape to systematically
understand
human disease
so
i'm going to now switch to the second
part of the talk about the three
applications and i'm going to first talk
about genomic association
studies and the most significant hits
and how we can interpret them and gain
new insights into human disease and then
i'm going to talk about how
we can use that to actually start
looking at weakly associated regions and
somatic variants associated with cancer
so what are the goals in dissecting
non-coding associations as i mentioned
earlier what we need to understand first
is
given a region of association that spans
many genetic variants
what is the relevant tissue and cell
type in which this is acting
number two
we'd like to know for these non-coding
regions
who are the target genes that are
actually being targeted by these regions
and these target genes as i'm going to
show in this part of the talk can sit
more than one million nucleotides away
number three we want to understand who
are the causal nucleotides that are
responsible for these associations
and find map these regions in order to
then understand the disregulatory event
for the upstream regulators that are
targeting these causal nucleotides
and then lastly we need to understand
the cellular phenotypes and the organism
of phenotypes that arise from these
these regulatory events
and this sounds very daunting but the
tools that i mentioned earlier combined
with directed experimentation in the
relevant cell types that we can predict
using these approaches
and disruption of the specific
regulators and the specific nucleotides
and the specific target genes that are
predicted by these approaches can in
fact allow us to dissect these
and in this talk i'll focus on the work
by melina klausner
applying these tools to the fto locus
so what is the fdo locus it is the
strongest association with obesity it
actually spans 47 000 nucleotides in
chromosome 16
and
they sit exactly in the first intron of
the fto gene
the challenge however there's a very
large number of genetic variants that
are all associated with the phenotype of
obesity cardiovascular traits and type 2
diabetes but we don't really know which
one is the causal one and the very large
span of this region makes it very
difficult to understand the phenotype
there are no protein altering variants
in this region
leading many to suggest that it might
play as a regulatory role but the target
gene as well as the relevant cell type
is actually not known
so we set out to uncover these using a
systematic study
so there's been a large number of
conflicting proposals some people
propose that fdo itself is a target
some people propose that it is irx3
acting in pancreas others have proposed
that it is rx3 acting in the brain
others have proposed that it's another
gene acting in the brain or it's another
gene acting lymphocytes leading to a
large number of answers and
all conflicting with each other so we
basically decided to take an unbiased
approach and basically look at these
epigenomic annotation maps to predict
the relevant tissue and cell type and we
looked at these maps across 127fp
genomes that i mentioned earlier
specifically for the sto locus and what
we found is that these maps light up
specifically in mesenchymal
pre-adipocytes so these are the stem
cells that actually give rise to both
the adipose lineage and
other lineages and these are the cells
specifically that give rise to both
white adipocytes and
bright or beige adipocytes
and these enhancers are much longer in
these regions than for any other locus
so to understand if the genetic variant
associated with fto with obesity in the
fdo locus
is in fact changing the expression of
that enhancer we carried out enhancer
assays for both the non-risk and the
risk
haplotype
in 10kb segments and what we found is
pretty striking validating our
prediction that adipocytes are in fact
relevant we found a very strong increase
in enhancer activity specifically for
the risk hablotype
but not for the non-risk haplotype
suggesting in fact that the genetic
variant associated with the disease is
leading to gain of regulatory activity
in this particular region
and we validated that this is specific
to adipocytes and not found in neuronal
cells muscle cells or any other cell
type
so the next thing we did is in fact um
ask whether uh this is in fact changing
the expression of target genes in this
locus
so to predict target genes we basically
looked at the topological domain that is
associated with this fto genetic variant
and it actually spans 2.5 megabases of
interactions both upstream of this
variant and downstream of this variant
giving us a total of eight candidate
genes and to basically look for genotype
dependent expression levels we gathered
a cohort of 20 homozygous risk and
making homozygous non-risk individuals
and for each of them we gathered adipose
samples and differentiated
pre-adipocytes for each of these samples
and what we found was pretty striking
there are exactly two genes among these
eight candidates that show differential
expression and this is very significant
and these genes are sitting strikingly
far
500 kv and 1.1 megabases away from the
specific fto locus
so this suggests that these are the only
two targets that are
specifically differentially expressed
between risk and non-risk individuals in
pre-adipocytes
and again these show increased
expression for the risk allele
consistent with the enhancer change of
activity
we next turn to predict the causal
nucleotide variant and for this we use
two approaches the first approach is
actually regulatory motif enrichment
across
bmi hits across the whole genome and the
second is an approach previously
published by melina klausner who
actually led this study that actually
looked at regulatory motif combinations
that are evolutionarily conserved across
mammals and the two approaches agreed
that this particular region
of of these fdo locus in the first 10 kb
interval is in fact the most likely to
be causal as it has the highest score
and the highest concentration of
enriched regulatory motifs
and the specific risk variant alters a t
to a c
abolishing this 80 rich motif that
overlaps this particular region
so indeed we found that making that
single nucleotide alteration
changed the activity of these enhancers
and was able to lead to higher activity
in the non-risk individuals by
introducing the single nucleotide change
we use that to now start looking at the
upstream regulators that might actually
be targeting this predicted causal
nucleotide and we found
that there are three candidates the arid
family of regulators and two additional
regulators that have similar motifs that
overlap this locus
among them the most enriched is by far
the arid 5b regulator
that is the most expressed in both whole
adipose tissue from both lean and obese
individuals and in isolated adipocytes
from both risk and non-risk individuals
so the model is the following that the
arid 5b repressor
would normally bind the dna motif which
is at rich and repress enhancer activity
thereby shutting off both irx3 and rx5
but in the risk individuals the motif
would be lost
leading to lack of repression and
therefore
gain of expression for both rx3 and rx5
and that's exactly what we found we
found that in order to successfully
repress the enhancer you need to have
the intact motif and you need to have
the intact regulator but if you disrupt
either of the two you basically get a
gain of enhancer activity
similarly to repress irix 3 or rx-5 you
need again the intact motif and
regulator
but
de-repressing uh i mean disrupting
either of the two in fact leads to a
gain of activity
so that suggests that repression of the
enhancer is in fact the causal mechanism
that's leading to this this regulation
of rx3 and rx5 that might underlie
the seo association with obesity
so we have uncovered the regulatory
circuitry of the fto genetic association
with obesity but we don't know yet how
does this circuitry actually lead to
obesity and in order to do that we need
to understand the cellular and the
organism of phenotypes that are affected
to do this we basically carried out a
co-expression analysis across a large
number of individuals
to look for genes that are positively
and negatively correlated with rx3 and
rx5 and we found a large number of genes
that in fact cluster in a small number
of pathways the genes that are most
negatively correlated are associated
with mitochondrial function and the
genes that are most positively
correlated are associated with lipid
metabolism
and indeed these changes in gene
expression are reflected in the cellular
phenotypic differences between risk and
non-risk individuals we find that the
risk individuals have much lower dna
content for the mitochondria suggesting
a reduced mitochondrial number and they
also have a higher size of adipocyte
suggesting accumulation of lipids so the
model is that the risk allele is in fact
leading to a shift from energy
dissipation to energy storage and in
particular we find that in risk
individuals the uncoupling protein 1 ucp
1 that depolarizes the mitochondrial
membrane leading to import of protons
and
loss of energy through heat
is in fact much lower
for the risk allele individuals than for
the protective allele individuals and
that the protectively individuals are in
fact able to respond to either cold
stimulus or brain stimuli associated
with a generation of heat
and increase the expression of that gene
thereby increasing thermogenesis
uh but this response is actually lost in
the risk allele patients
so the model is very simple it basically
says that the rh5v repressor
is in fact uh no longer able to repress
the corresponding enhancer in
pre-adipocytes leading to an increase in
rx-3 and rx-5 expression and shutting
off thermogenesis and turning on uh
fat storage
and we carried out a series of
experiments that i'll go through briefly
to actually validate that model
including knockdown of rs3 and rx5 which
according to our model should lead to
anti-obesity phenotypes
over expression of rx3 and rx5 which
should lead to probative phenotypes as
well as perturbations of the regulator
motif itself and of the upstream
regulator so i'll go through them rather
quickly to basically say that indeed in
rx3 uh
an irk3 repression has a specific gain
of thermogenesis
in risk individuals
leading to non-risk levels
and the corresponding over expression of
rx3 leads to loss of thermogenesis
specifically in the protective allele
individuals matching uh risk allele
levels indeed showing that iris drain
rx5 are causal
in mouse
down regulation of rx3 has very strong
anti-obesity phenotypes which are much
stronger than the same repression in
brain indicating that this
variant is acting and these genes are
acting primarily in adipocytes and these
mice lose the ability to gain weight
even in a high fat diet
we also find that
these mice are in fact showing increased
energy expenditure
both at night and during the day when
they're sleeping suggesting that this is
not due to increased activity and this
is not due to reduced fat
food intake
knocking down the regulator as again pro
obesity phenotypes exactly as the model
would expect and these are happening
specifically in the protective allele
individuals
we're finding that
the corresponding changes of the
regulatory
variant
using genome editing in vivo are in fact
able to reverse the phenotypic
signatures of obesity in the risk
individuals or in fact lead to the
pro-obesity signatures in non-risk
individuals
so we've in fact edited this allele in a
bi-directional way
starting with non-risk individuals and
then editing the allele to a c
and then showing that that leads to gain
of rx3 expression and then editing that
edited allele back to a t and showing
that represses both rx3 and rx5
we've also taken the specific nucleotide
variant from the risk individuals and
shown that by editing it
we're in fact able to reverse the gene
expression specifically when irish 5b is
expressed but not
when rfib is knocked down again showing
causality at the nucleotide level the
last thing we found is that
this variant is acting specifically in
early adipocyte differentiation for both
our exterior rx5 but that the difference
in expression goes away
by day four or six of differentiation
so what that suggests is that
um
and in fact the last thing we did in
fact show that the the thermogenesis
signature
in these risk individuals can be
completely rescued by editing that
single nucleotide variant so that in
fact establishes causality of that
single nucleotide variant in fact
driving the cellular signatures of
obesity
so the model is very simple it basically
says that these mesenchymal stem cells
can differentiate either into white
adipocytes
that store energy or into basia
liposides that burn energy and that the
shift between the two is controlled by
this one nucleotide variant which
actually leads to a seven pound
difference in weight between risk and
non-risk individuals not because of a
change in
brain expression or because of a change
in appetite or exercise but because of a
change specifically in the adipocytes of
these individuals
and there's a very large number of
genetic variants that are yet to be
discovered and those methods are in fact
very general and should allow us to now
start dissecting a large number of
variants associated with a diversity of
disorders
i'm going to very briefly mention our
work on
using epigenomics to reveal weak but
functional variants and this is
basically looking at the sub-threshold
variants that are associated with
disease
but have very small effects
and our work in a
large number of traits indicates that
there's a large fraction of uh missing
and hidden heritability across different
individuals and there's been a growing
understanding of our field
that in fact even within our
genotyping arrays there's a large number
of variants that remain hidden that are
sitting in these sub-threshold locus
so what we did is
first ask how far down the rank list do
these genetic enrichments persist
for the straight relevant
uh enhancers and they persist very very
far down the rank list suggesting that
there's a large number of variants and
we focus specifically on um two
um
on on cardiac trait to basically try to
elucidate the function of these variants
so we looked at the sub threshold
variance between ten to the minus eight
and ten to the minus five and we found
that there's a large number of
epigenomic signatures that allow us to
now start prioritizing them
systematically
by training on the genome-wide
significant hit and then applying it to
predict sub-threshold variance
we have in fact gone off and validated a
large number of these variants showing
that in 11
in nine of 11 tested cases we do find
allelic activity
and in some cases we're able to now go
and show specifically
in zebrafish embryos that by altering
these uh genes that are targeted by
these sub-threshold variants we actually
can lead to a change in the heart
repolarization duration in order to
discover that association we would have
needed three times as many individuals
as what we had now
but
by actually using epigenomic information
we're able to
elucidate those with only a third of the
individuals uh indicating the power and
importance of epigenomic information for
prioritizing these self-threshold
variants
the last thing we looked at is
somatic mutations that are associated
with cancer gene dysregulation
so the model there is that a large
number of
dispersed mutations
would in fact be found in the regulatory
neighborhood of cancer genes
but all target the same gene and lead to
its dysregulation
so in order to understand that we
basically
searched for
cancer tumor pairs that were
dysregulated and we identified that
nearly five times as many genes are
upregulated in cancer versus down
regulated in cancer indicating
that
might be a common mechanism of action
and indeed the genes that show
de-repression are in fact very strongly
enriched for a large number of these
non-coding variants in their regulatory
neighborhood and those variants are
primarily sitting in enhancer regions
which are active in other tissues and
cell types rather than specifically in
the cancer in which these variants
appear to be acting and the region is
again the reason is again a
de-repression model for cancer where
regulatory elements are now utilized out
of context similar to the
change that we saw in the sto variant
so we built a model that allows us to
now estimate from the genome by genome
sampling
what the expected mutation rate should
be for each of the genes based on the
regulatory neighborhood and then use
these expectations to now calculate an
enrichment for each of those genes that
allows us to now predict
new cancer genes
based on the enrichment of their
regulatory plexus and you can see here
that these plexi can be extremely
complex or extremely simple
but
in both cases we find a large number of
new genes that are associated with
cancer they're in fact falling in a
small number of pathways that are
already known to play roles in cancer
so to summarize we basically looked at a
systematic characterization of the
epigenomic landscape that we can then
utilize to mechanistically dissect
disease-associated loci using these
public data sets generated by the
roadmap genomics projects and the encode
project
and
systematic experimentation in
relevant cell types we also saw briefly
how we can in fact utilize these
genomics to understand weakly associated
regions that are functional even though
they do not meet genomic significant
threshold and to understand somatic
alterations that are associated with
cancer
the first part uh the first application
was in collaboration with melina
klausmanter who's
a professor at harvard and has been
spending a postdoc in my lab as well and
the second part was a
work by sinchen wang in collaboration
with lori boyer in the mit biology
department and the last part is led by
uh richard solari uh who's a postdoc in
my group
and this is all in the context of the
roadmap of genomics project which is
funded by nih and uh we're also funded
partially by the nhgri so i'll stop
there go back to my outline slide and
i'll be very happy to take any questions
well thank you dr kellis for that very
informative presentation
before we get started on the q a session
i'd like to remind our audience that you
can submit questions by typing them in
the q a box which can be found by
clicking the green q a button to the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
well if there are no if there are no
questions
i'd like to take this opportunity to
once again thank dr kellis
and i'd like to also remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing for six months
from today's live event you will receive
an email from laproots alerting you that
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
i'll wait just one minute for a few more
questions if uh if uh if anybody wants
to send them we have a few minutes left
i want to also thank you all for
listening and uh
my email is manoli mit.edu i'll be very
happy to take any questions by email as
well
and
i guess this stuff will be available so
feel free to reach out to myself or any
members of my lab to answer any
questions
great well thank you all for joining us
today thank you guys next time
bye
bye